- [Voiceover] 1945 really
represents the final
throes of World War II.
In Europe, you might
remember, at the end of 1944,
we have the Battle of the Bulge starting,
which is an incredibly bloody battle.
The U.S. forces, which
kind of take the brunt
on the Allied side, lose
roughly 20,000 troops,
but by January, they're
able to break through
and invade Germany.
So as you go into early 1945, the Allies
are on their march
through Western Germany.
Now if you go on the east, the Russians
or the Soviets are also marching westward.
By January of 1945, they're
able to take Warsaw,
and from there, they continue to march
westward towards Berlin.
Now the writing is on
the wall at this point.
The Allies look like
they are going to win,
and so they meet at
Yalta, the major powers,
to discuss what happens to Europe
after World War II.
What happens to Germany?
Is it split up?
What influence will the different
Allied victors have in
the different countries
of World War II?
So this is happening in
Yalta in February of 1945.
Let me write that down.
That's in February.
All the while this is happening,
even though the writing is on the wall
that the Allies are going to win the war,
they weren't taking anything for granted.
They wanted to absolutely
force a surrender
by the Axis powers in
Germany in particular.
So they continue to firebomb major cities
of Germany, and firebombing
is an incredibly
devastating form of bombing, where you're
literally trying to destroy the city,
set the city on fire.
The most notable of these cities that
were firebombed were Hamburg and Dresden.
The firebombing of
Dresden, movies and books
are written about it.
The Nazis did also firebomb London,
but that didn't have quite the same
devastating effect as
the Allied firebombing
of Hamburg and Dresden, and actually
of Tokyo and other Japanese cities,
as we will see in a few minutes.
But then everything really comes to a head
in April of 1945.
It's in April that as you can see,
as you get into April and May,
the Allies are able to essentially
occupy major chunks of Germany.
They're able to push Axis forces
outside of Italy.
They have effectively won.
Mussolini gets captured
and then gets executed.
Soviets are able to take Berlin,
and maybe most importantly, April 30th,
Hitler commits suicide.
So, Hitler commits suicide,
and he's not the only one.
Several other major leaders,
Nazi leaders, commit suicide as we
go into this period right over here.
Essentially the war is won in Europe
at this point, and that's made official
on May 8th, May 8th, which is a good
day to remember, known as VE Day,
Victory in Europe, Victory in Europe Day.
So the Allies have won in Europe,
but everything is not over yet.
World War II is still
going on in the Pacific.
So let's go down to the Pacific Theater.
Starting the year in January,
the Allies are able to
take the Island of Luzon.
In particular, they're
able to take Manila.
Then, as we go into February, they began
the invasion of Iwo Jima, which is
an incredibly bloody campaign.
You have 70,000 marines invade the island
verus 22,000 Japanese troops.
On top of that you obviously have air,
you have the Air Force involved,
you have the Navy involved, but I guess
what's even more mind-boggling, you have
significant Allied deaths.
You have 7,000 deaths on the Allied side,
but even more amazing, out of the 22,000
Japanese soldiers that were defending
Iwo Jima, 19,000 get killed.
So 19,000 of 22,000 Japanese
soldiers get killed.
So you can imagine how bloody this is.
And this picture, which is probably
one of the most famous military photos
ever taken, especially
in the United States,
this was taken of Marines storming a hill,
storming a mountain in Iwo Jima.
And just to imagine how
bloody these things are.
I just gave you some of the numbers.
Even this photo, which
is a real photograph,
even this photo, where it looks like
hey look, the Americans
have at least taken
this mountain or this
hill right over here,
even out of this photo,
three of these Marines
die in the next few days as they continue
to try to take Iwo Jima
or take the entire island.
So you can imagine the Japanese
were able to mount a ferocious
defense of the island.
They aren't able to fully take the island
until we get into March.
So by March, so maybe
I'll say February to March
you have the invasion of Iwo Jima.
Now the whole time that this is happening,
you have B-29s firebombing major cities
in Japan, and especially Tokyo.
So once again, these cities
are really being destroyed.
This is all-out war.
But still the Japanese
have not surrendered.
So in April, actually
April going into June,
you have to remember April in Europe,
this is when it was pretty much done with.
Hitler commits suicide in April.
But in April going into June of 1945,
you have the Allied invasion of Okinawa,
which once again, is an incredibly
bloody campaign.
You have above and beyond
the tens of thousands of Japanese soldiers
that get killed at Okinawa,
you have tens and tens of thousands
of civilians who get killed
or commit suicide.
So once again, this is all
very unpleasant and very bloody.
But we continue on, and still the Japanese
have not surrendered.
Although even in 1944, their navy
is all but destroyed,
but they're mounting
this ferocious defense.
In parallel to all of this, the Allies,
especially the U.S., has
had the Manhattan Project
to develop nuclear weapons, and they
decide to use them,
Truman is now president,
in order to accelerate the end of the war.
And so in August 6th, they drop
an atomic bomb on Hiroshima,
essentially destroying that city.
And it's interesting to read accounts
of how the Japanese learned about it
or what they didn't learn
about it, obviously.
Obviously no one was expecting bombs
that could just obliterate a city,
literally, in seconds.
Still, there wasn't a
surrender from the Japanese,
and so, let me write this.
This is August 6th, and so on August 9th,
you have another atomic
bomb dropped on Nagasaki.
At the same time that this is happening,
you have the Soviet
Union invading Manchuria.
You have the Soviet
Union invading Manchuria,
and so enough was enough.
You have the Soviets who are now getting
involved in the Pacific, the Americans
seem to be able to literally destroy
Japanese cities at will,
and so on August 14, 1945, you have
the Japanese surrender.
Japanese surrender, and then this does
not become truly official
until September 2, 1945,
which is called VJ Day,
Victory in Japan Day.
That marks the real end of World War II.
Obviously, World War II ended at the end
of April, May, officially
early May in Europe,
but now in early
September it is officially
ended in the Pacific as well.
And the Allies are victorious.